SASHA ARILANTO: OK.
So just to get an idea of who's
in the room, how many of you
guys have been to
SoulCycle before?
Because it doesn't
sound like you
guys have been to SoulCycle.
[CHEERING]
SASHA ARILANTO: Awesome.
Also, a quick announcement
is that MK is in the room.
A little bit starstruck.
A little more starstruck
for MK being here.
I mean, I love
Julie and Elizabeth.
ELIZABETH CUTLER: No question.
SASHA ARILANTO: So for those
of you who haven't been,
or for those of you who
just want a refresher,
we're going to watch a quick
video from SoulCycle to get us
in the mood for today.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - RACHEL PLATTEN, "FIGHT
SONG"]
-To take a risk and to jump.
In those rooms, we're telling
people to follow your dreams,
to try something new and
go where your heart is.
Because we certainly did that.
[MUSIC - RACHEL PLATTEN, "FIGHT
SONG"]
[MUSIC - GREGOR SALTO & WIWEEK,
"ON YOUR MARK"]
-SoulCycle is an
extraordinary place.
-It's an exercise community.
It's social and it's joyful
and you feel like a rock star.
-It's therapy.
It's escape.
It's fun.
-People come to us
for the workout,
but they stay for
the breakthroughs
that they have on the bike.
-People get to
change their lives,
their bodies, their attitude.
-You lose yourself
in the rhythm,
and you lose
yourself in the pack.
And you work way harder than
you ever would on your own.
-I love what I do
because I get to be
the best part of people's day.
[MUSIC - IVAN GOUGH AND
FEENIXPAWL, "IN MY MIND"]
[MUSIC - JACK U, "TAKE U THERE"]
-There are no words for
me to really describe it.
It is joy.
It is love.
It is community.
-You can have soulful moments.
You can cry.
You can laugh.
-It makes you feel
better about yourself.
It makes you feel
better about your day.
And it just works.
-When I think about SoulCycle,
what I find on the bike,
for me, it's love.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SASHA ARILANTO: Awesome.
So it's 2016 right now,
and I'm really [INAUDIBLE].
And this is the SoulCycle
I know and love.
I go there way too
often for my paycheck.
[LAUGHTER]
But what was the
first SoulCycle like?
It started 10 years
ago, which I think
is something that people
don't really realize.
I think that for a lot of
us, we got this SoulCycle.
And I can't imagine that the
first SoulCycle was like this.
So paint us a picture of
what that first early day
of SoulCycle was like.
ELIZABETH CUTLER: Well,
it wasn't like this
but it wasn't so
dissimilar from this,
which is one of the things
that's kind of exciting,
to see these early
seeds were there.
I first want to say, thank
you guys so much for having us
here.
This is an overwhelming,
amazing place to be,
that you guys spend
all your days in.
And I don't know if we really
realized that so many of you
have ridden before.
Which, thank you very
much for doing that.
Otherwise, maybe we would
have made a shorter video.
[LAUGHTER]
But the first studio was an
old dance studio on 72nd street
in New York City near a
bunch of express trains,
so we thought we could be
easy for people to get to.
We built it out of
Ikea, my station wagon.
We had an online
reservation system
that took the friction
out of going to your gym
and waiting for an hour
for your favorite class.
So you could sign
up for your classes
and plan your week around the
fitness that you wanted to do.
And the wheel was there
from the beginning.
We felt like we had
big aspirations.
Like, maybe sometime
in the future,
people will just see the
wheel and they'll just
think SoulCycle,
instead of us having
to have the word
associated with the wheel.
And it's exciting for us to
have seen that dream come true,
as we've gotten bigger
and have the opportunity
for actual signage,
which we didn't
have in our first location.
So not only could
nobody find it,
but we couldn't really leverage
the foot traffic of New York
City.
But we overcame that by loving
every single person that
came in the front door.
Because we were pretty blown
away that you had found us,
and really excited to
have you experience
what we thought it
was not just fitness,
but providing an experience
that was different than fitness.
That you could
find something else
in that room, whether
it was burning calories,
or whether it was
feeling stronger, or just
a real human experience.
So I think that kind
of paints a little bit
of the early picture.
JULIE RICE: Yeah.
Early days were
really interesting.
I mean, Elizabeth and
I were introduced.
We had both been taking
classes at different gyms
around the city.
And we had both been
talking to friends about,
we have this idea.
Exercise could be different.
It could be more
than just a workout.
It could really
be an experience.
And so we were introduced
by a mutual friend,
and we went to lunch.
And we always say it was
sort of the best blind date
that we'd ever been on.
And when I left lunch that
day, Elizabeth called me
and she said, here's
what's going to happen.
I'm going to go
look at real estate,
and you're going
to research towels.
And I thought, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
And by the way,
I'll let you know.
The first thing I did
when I got back to my desk
was I googled towels.
ELIZABETH CUTLER:
She had a desk.
JULIE RICE: By the way,
great-- Google, great service.
[LAUGHTER]
Turns out you
actually rent them.
You don't buy them.
But that being said,
Elizabeth called
me a couple of days
later and said,
you know, I found
something on Craigslist,
which is where we
found our first studio.
We certainly don't find our
studios on Craigslist anymore.
And it was the back of
a lobby of a building.
It was a funeral home that
had been turned into a dance
studio that was now for rent.
And we met there for
the second time ever.
And we looked around.
And it was tiny.
It was 1,500 square feet all in.
And our big purchase
with our seed money
was we sprung for a glass wall,
sort of a frosted glass wall,
that we had some guys
come-- so it divided
the studio from the reception.
And a plywood wall, which
was all we could afford,
that then divided the office,
which was about as big
as our three chairs behind it.
And we did.
We made all these trips to Ikea.
It took us three or four trips
through the Lincoln tunnel
to go to New Jersey.
SASHA ARILANTO: And at this
point, were y'all working also?
Was it a seamless transition
from the old job to new job?
Was it a side project?
JULIE RICE: So I was working.
I worked in the movie
business at the time.
And I was sort of getting burned
out on the type of culture that
was the entertainment industry.
I had just moved from
California to New York City.
And I was really missing the
social aspect of what I had,
living on the west
coast, with exercise.
There were certainly
a lot of great ways
to burn calories in
New York, but I really
missed what was a very
big part of my life
when I lived on the
west coast, which
was exercise and the people
that I knew and exercised
with really being my community.
SASHA ARILANTO: And
when you started,
this was both of
y'all's second career.
You had children.
You were married, I think.
Arguably adults.
So it wasn't like-- you
had responsibilities.
So on one hand, I think
some people might think,
oh, you had maybe cash,
you had experience.
But also, you had a
lot of commitments.
Was that scary?
Especially with people telling
you, this isn't going to work.
There's no market for this.
JULIE RICE: I mean,
let's be clear.
Nobody thought this was going
to work, my parents especially.
[LAUGHTER]
There was nobody who
thought this was working.
ELIZABETH CUTLER: People
were like, you know
spinning is completely dead?
There's no reason to do this.
JULIE RICE: It's true.
But beyond spinning being
dead, the crazy thing for us
was that there was no
boutique fitness at all.
There were yoga studios
in New York City,
and people were not paying
per class for fitness.
The real concept was, you belong
to a gym, you pay a membership.
If anybody knows what
the gym model looks like,
their profitability is not with
their group fitness programs.
It's the add-ons that
you buy at a gym.
And so nobody really
thought that this
was a model that was something
that would really work.
ELIZABETH CUTLER: But
we definitely knew
that it would work.
JULIE RICE: We did.
ELIZABETH CUTLER: No,
seriously, we totally
did know that it would work.
JULIE RICE: It really has
informed our entire experience.
Because we have always looked
at the pay-per-class model
as a challenge to
ourselves, right?
We're only as good as
the last time you came.
So we've always thought of
it as a mini-production.
It's curtain up, curtain
down, every time you come.
From the front desk person
who knows your name,
or remembers that you like your
water at a certain temperature,
or has your rental shoes in
your size waiting for you.
And when you get there, you
think, god, that person really
knows me, right?
To the way that the
instructor engages with you.
The way that you're
sent out into the world
high on endorphins,
feeling a little bit better
about yourself.
And so we really, as we were
360 designing this experience,
and thinking about
all the pillars
that we wanted to
put in to make sure
that this experience touched
you in many different ways.
We knew that, if we
challenged ourselves
to deliver that every time, that
people would pay to come back.
SASHA ARILANTO: I
have to say, too,
that I was probably the
biggest skeptic of SoulCycle
before I went.
And the other day,
Kamel knew my name,
and he called me
a Kamellionaire.
I told my mom.
I literally told my mom.
Happier than someone with--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
SASHA ARILANTO: It was like
a huge-- I felt really--
I don't know other people
who go to SoulCycle,
besides the people
I already knew.
But I do feel part
of that community.
But before, I was
a huge skeptic.
I was like, that's stupid.
There's this girl
in my down, and I
was like, I can believe
she pays all of that money.
It's just because her
dad works at Bain.
[LAUGHTER]
I've become that girl.
And my dad does
not work at Bain.
So once you have people in
the door, they transform.
But before you have the
bang behind everyone saying,
SoulCycle's the
greatest thing, how
do you convince
investors and customers,
this is something you
should spend a lot of money
and your valuable time
in New York City to do?
ELIZABETH CUTLER:
So it's two things.
One is, we self-funded.
So that we had to
convince ourselves.
So that was a little bit
easier than convincing
other people, who totally
didn't believe in us at all.
Which is obviously a
unique position to be in,
but it was not-- we
were super scrappy,
and took out the garbage, and
only spent money on the things
that we needed to.
And the people who
worked at the front desk
also babysat for our kids.
So there was a lot
of cross-pollination
going on there that worked
really, really well.
And then I think the
second thing is we really
realized early on you
value what you pay for.
So if you're going
to pay for something,
you're going to show up on time.
You're going to
bring your-- you're
going to try to get
something out of it.
And it elevates the
vibe in the room.
And particularly when--
You know, listen.
People get so distracted.
There are so many things
biting at us all day long.
I need this, I need that,
I need this, I need that.
To spend 45 minutes not only
checking off your workout,
but also having something that's
an experience for you that's
unplugged.
And normally, we're-- we
have external central nervous
systems now, which is awesome.
But I do think that
there is a place for this
in the kind of culture
that we're living in now.
And it really is
a question of-- we
always talk about, it's
either two cocktails,
inexpensive personal training.
A friend of mine is
like, it's five coffees.
I'm just going to drink my own
coffee that I make at home.
And you just figure out
where your value system is.
SASHA ARILANTO: And now that
you guys are head honchos,
do y'all go all the time?
ELIZABETH CUTLER:
We've always ridden.
We made it for us.
JULIE RICE: We are.
I mean, we've always
been the user.
In fact, I was watching
the video thinking,
I'm so bummed that I didn't
get on a bike this morning.
Truthfully, that's what I was
thinking during the video.
It's always been for us.
That we were
absolutely two people
that were looking for an
experience that did not exist.
And that's why we created it.
It continues to be for us.
I ride usually about
five times a week.
I always say, the
one thing for me
is I usually try to ride--
we have a studio attached
to our office.
I can assure you, our
offices are awesome.
They don't look like Google,
but they are terrific.
And we have a great studio,
which is one of our big perks,
is that we have a studio
attached to our office.
But I always try to ride not in
the studio next to our office,
because I say it's like
when you're home on Saturday
trying to get work done,
and then you realize, mm,
you could clean your
closet because you've
been meaning to for a while.
And inevitably I
get lost at my desk
if I don't work out
in a different studio
before I get there.
SASHA ARILANTO: That's
how I feel, too.
So I want to touch on something,
Elizabeth, that you mentioned.
Is that you had a system that
was extremely innovative.
That you can book.
Y'all were the first
people, I think,
to have a booking
system for a spot.
Which, I think a
lot of people would
say if they could
book their yoga mat,
they probably would get in
a lot less spiritual fights.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm trying to think about
how innovative that is.
Because in 2005 or
2006, for perspective,
I was in seventh grade.
I had a T-Mobile Sidekick.
iPhones didn't exist.
Apps literally did not
exist when y'all did this.
What was the impetus for
that sort of innovation?
ELIZABETH CUTLER: Again,
it came down to need.
And we decided, it is so
stupid that you are showing up
at a gym to sign up
on paper for something
that you could do online.
And it was great
to do that early,
because you barely were ordering
food online 10 years ago.
And what we kind
of felt like was
we wanted to have a place where
people could come and start
to seed a community.
And really, it's kind of fun.
If you're signing
up for classes,
you can figure out what
bike you're going to be on,
and you can be
messaging your friend,
all right, I'm going
to be on this bike,
and you're going
to be on that bike.
And in that way, there's
kind of a community vibe
that starts to come out of it.
And it's actually great.
Because people come to our site.
SASHA ARILANTO: And I wonder--
this is the Googler in me,
and also the paranoia.
How do you guys use that data?
Because I feel like
you could get a lot.
Like what bikes
people want to be in,
what studios are popular.
Does that data inform
business decisions?
ELIZABETH CUTLER:
Well, we don't have
as many people
working at SoulCycle
as you guys do at Google.
So we have--
SASHA ARILANTO:
[INAUDIBLE] in the data.
ELIZABETH CUTLER: We
have access to some data,
but certainly not on the level
that you guys think about it.
But look, I think
data is important.
Because it helps you
sort of figure out
what people-- I don't
need to tell you guys
what's important about data.
I mean, you guys invented data.
JULIE RICE: What people want.
Definitely we look at
our data to figure out
all sorts of things
about the business.
We're not trying to be creepy
and look at personal habits.
But we do use it to inform
business decisions, absolutely.
SASHA ARILANTO: OK, cool.
And this is sort of at
that level, too, of when
you're creating your brand.
And something you
mentioned, that you created
this product for yourself.
And I think-- I brought two of
my friends, who are both males,
to SoulCycle for the first time.
And they said,
kind of hesitantly,
it's kind of a
girl's experience.
And y'all are women.
Did that--
JULIE RICE: Did they say
that after or before?
SASHA ARILANTO:
They said before.
Yeah, after.
After, they were like, uhh!
They're dying.
I look over, and I'm
really proud of myself.
Because I'm hitting the
tapbacks, and they're flailing.
[LAUGHTER]
It's another thing where
you have to get someone in.
But do you guys see that as
a weakness of the product?
Or it's fine?
Do you think you'll
ever make SoulCycle more
dude-friendly or bro-friendly?
ELIZABETH CUTLER: There's so
many dudes in the classes now,
though.
When we first started,
it was a lot of women.
It really was.
But I think women
tend to bring guys.
Women create communities
much more so than men do.
JULIE RICE: I think the other
thing is, we created it for us,
but we were very, very
sure in the beginning
that we were creating a
brand, not just a studio.
And I think that even way
back in the beginning, when
we had no right to picture
the brand as the Nike swoosh
or anything like that, we did.
And we were fanatical about
everything from the graphics
that we used to the colors
that we chose to the voice
that we wrote with.
And we really decided
to plant a flag
and make sure that this brand
did have a real identity
and a real strong voice.
And I think with
any great brand,
it really stands for something.
And you really can
hear it talking,
and you can understand
what it feels like
and what you're supposed
to feel like when
you're there and in it.
And so for us, we absolutely
took a point of view
on what this brand was
going to feel like.
And even though it was
created by two chicks,
I don't think that
there's anything
about being an
athlete or a renegade
or a rock star that doesn't
speak to every gender.
SASHA ARILANTO: For sure.
ELIZABETH CUTLER:
And generation.
JULIE RICE: Correct.
ELIZABETH CUTLER:
It's fun to see.
It's not just men and women.
It's kids, it's older people,
it's everybody in between.
SASHA ARILANTO: And
with that, though, it
does seem, though, that
standing in a SoulCycle,
you can kind of get the
vibe of the type of people
who go there.
Which may be because of price
or where these studios go.
As y'all are expanding, do
you see that as a challenge,
to get a different clientele?
One that-- maybe more
middle America than Miami.
Do you think that that's-- how
is that affecting the vision,
if at all, for y'all?
ELIZABETH CUTLER: I think
this goes back to what
you're getting from the bike.
Because for me, it's
a human experience.
So I think we sell fitness.
That's our core business.
But what's really
going on in that room
has a lot to do with where
you are in your life.
And it doesn't matter
where you live.
If you live in Kansas, it's
very much a similar experience.
Your sister can
be sick in Kansas
just like your sister can
be sick in California.
And if you're the one
who's being strong for her,
and you're finding your
strength on that bike
to go back into the
rest of your life
and inspire those around you.
Or just be your best person.
There's so much value in
being your best person.
I don't think that-- I think
that transcends demographic.
I think it transcends
parts of the country.
JULIE RICE: I think what we're
seeing as a macro trend is
that health is the new wealth.
That people want experiences,
they don't want stuff.
And I do think that if it was
something that 10 years ago we
might have thought about
when we started the business,
I really think that
people everywhere
are ready to feel good
and have better health
and be a little bit
less stressed out.
ELIZABETH CUTLER:
And super strong,
to your point of kicking
your friend's ass.
SASHA ARILANTO: I
mean, you guys saw him.
He's 6'2".
He's got little-- he
does curls for the girls.
So we know that-- I was proud.
But to that point of
how it transcends.
It's that experience.
It's not so much-- that
transcends demographic.
I've noticed that SoulCycle
is very much experience-based.
You never see before
and after pictures.
Maybe casually there's the
mention of how many calories
you burn.
And especially given
the Equinox partnership,
which is all "Body by Equinox."
It's very results-driven, but
SoulCycle is very experience.
Is that something
that's intentional?
Do you ever tout that,
the effect of SoulCycle
in terms of actual fitness?
Building strength, cardio?
ELIZABETH CUTLER: The
proof is in the pudding.
It's in people's experience.
The letters that we get.
We're so highly engaged
with our community,
because we were so
desperate for people
to come in the beginning.
So we respond to every single
email, every single tweet.
And as a result, people
share their stories with us
very readily.
And I don't think we're
tracking how many pounds people
have actually lost.
But losing 72 pounds
is a big deal.
Losing 98 pounds is a big deal.
Losing 25 pounds is a huge deal.
And consistently, you're
seeing this coming through.
But the best part about
it is that it kind of
goes back to what we were
talking about before.
It's not the weight loss.
It's the, I lost 25
pounds, but that's not
what really happened.
I'm happier, I'm
smarter, I'm clearer,
I'm having a better life.
I met somebody.
I do this.
My whole landscape of how
I interact with the world
has completely shifted,
and I just feel better.
Who doesn't want to feel better?
JULIE RICE: And we consider
the fitness the baseline.
We don't feel the
need to say, oh,
you are going to look better.
You're going to lose weight.
You're going to burn between
500 and 800 calories every time
you come.
And we can promise you that.
That we can-- it's not that
there's no magic in that.
But if you're doing the
workout for 45 minutes,
you are going to lose
weight, look better, have
better cardiovascular health.
There's no doubt about it.
So it's one of those sort of,
what else are you getting?
SASHA ARILANTO:
And that experience
is so driven by these
instructors, who
are celebrities.
And I know, Julie, you were in
talent management before this.
So I imagine that you're
bringing some of those skills.
What were you looking
for in the beginning?
And now, to this day, how do you
know if someone's going to fit?
Because not all the
instructors are the same.
They each have their own brand.
But they're all very SoulCycle.
JULIE RICE: Yes.
Well, they're all trained
to teach SoulCycle.
We audition hundreds
of people a month
now for our coveted
instructor positions.
And we only take about 20
into every eight-week training
program that we do.
So we see all kinds of people.
We actually spend
a lot of time now
actually recruiting, not
just waiting for people
to come to us.
But we're out in the world
always actively looking.
It's really about charisma.
It's about being able to deliver
a certain kind of message.
These guys are great DJs.
We teach them the workout.
We teach them
music appreciation.
We teach them how to
create an emotional arc
that you, as a rider, come
through and experience.
But I really think--
the first thing
I think about when I
meet somebody or think
about them as potential
SoulCycles is, do I
want to spend 45 minutes
with this person?
Is something that
they are saying
to me-- am I going to react
to this person in a way
that something that
they are saying to me
is something I'm actually
going to listen to?
It's going to help
me to break through,
and it's going to
help me to become
a better version of myself.
Because let's be realistic.
We all walk through the
world, and you meet people,
and in one second you
say to yourself, mm,
not listening to that
person's opinion.
That person, put that back
here and use it for something.
And I really think that
is the first thing.
Are they charismatic
and credible
in a way that they
are going to be
able to ignite this kind
of motivation in people?
SASHA ARILANTO: And so as you
scale that talent management,
talent acquisition piece--
and y'all started as co-CEOs,
and you're no longer
that position.
How do you train
that into the people
who are working for you, who
are now doing the recruiting?
And how do you trust them
to know what you've really
cultivated yourself?
JULIE RICE: We have a
great recruiting team.
It's made up of quite a few
different types of people.
Not everybody-- that's the
great thing about people, right?
So when you say that the
SoulCycle experience is--
they're all SoulCycle,
but they're all
with different people.
And the person that
moves me is not
going to be the
person that moves you.
And that's really why
having a team of people that
are out in the world looking at
potential instructors is great.
Because what I like
and what gets to
me might be different than
what she likes and gets to her.
So we look at these
auditions, then we really all
sit in a room and vote.
It's awesome.
It's the best day.
It's the best day of
the month, for sure.
But we all have really
different opinions.
But I do think that
the common thread is
that charisma and that
leadership ability
that we look for.
And a lot of the
people on the team
have come from
talent backgrounds.
You'd be really surprised.
We're not looking for
people to come out
of the fitness industry.
A lot of our scouts have
come right out of Hollywood.
Most of our instructors,
at this point,
come from dancing
backgrounds, choreography.
Broadway shows are closing, and
who's free to teach on a bike
now?
And I think we're looking
in less likely avenues
for these type of people.
SASHA ARILANTO: Yeah.
And I can see that, too, to
the piece of-- I go to a class,
they're all different.
But I know my day
of the week based
on whose class I'm going to.
You got Todd, this
crazy firefighter--
literal firefighter.
And then you have a spunky
dancer the next day.
That's got to be nice
to know that you're
reaching a wide demographic
with all these very
different instructors.
ELIZABETH CUTLER: It's true.
And the thing is, we
just wanted to create
fitness careers for people.
Because before, people would
pick up one thing here,
and one thing there.
And by the time they
got to their next thing,
they were exhausted.
You're never going to
have a good experience.
And if we gave
people a home where
they had proper
benefits and great pay
and all that sort
of thing, and they
could take their inspiration,
just like you guys do here,
and apply it to
their jobs, there's
so much magic that
can happen, in that
you're really investing in
somebody's human potential.
And that was something different
that we did in the beginning
that I think has really spoken
to the DNA of the brand going
forward.
SASHA ARILANTO: And with that
very transformative experience,
I have to say, when
I started SoulCycle,
Cycle I was in a tough place.
I was going through
a really bad breakup.
I was making a lot of changes.
I became a vegan.
I meditated every
day of my life.
And literally the only change
that has stuck is SoulCycle.
The breakup didn't even
stick, to be honest.
ELIZABETH CUTLER:
That's awesome.
SASHA ARILANTO: So thank you.
And I have to tell you,
you've changed my life.
I think, how many company
starters can say, yeah,
this girl told me her New Year's
resolution was to literally buy
more of my products.
What does that feel like?
For someone to say,
hey, you helped
me get over depression, or
over my eating disorder.
I was going through
such a hard time
and your product
changed my life.
JULIE RICE: Two
things I want to say.
First of all, when
you asked before about
the physical benefits
of SoulCycle,
I think to your point of
something that sticks.
Any exercise can
run around and say,
we can change your
body in 10 days.
Yeah, and on day 11 we
can also change your body
back to the way that it
looked before, right?
So for us, it was really
about finding something
that we could make fun.
We always say SoulCycle
is like slipping
the spinach into the ice cream.
Our secret about
changing your body
and making sure you have results
is that if you love doing it,
you keep doing it, right?
So anything that you keep doing
for two or three or 10 years,
you're going to look
really, really good.
But to the point of people
whose lives are changing
and getting healthier
and happier.
For us, this whole thing, from
having a vision and a dream,
and putting some
words up on a wall,
and building a front
desk out of Ikea,
and being users that
wanted this product,
and watching our
first class sell out,
and then watching our
50th studio be built,
and getting thousands
of letters every year
about people that want this
thing all over the world, and--
ELIZABETH CUTLER: And
working with the most amazing
human beings.
JULIE RICE: --who are all
really carrying the torches,
and the people that are
scaling this and making this
happen every day.
It's beyond, really, a dream.
And then you add in
the fact that this
is a product that
is actually making
the world a little better.
It's a privilege.
It's really a privilege that
we don't take for granted ever.
Vicky, who's here, who
did a great job getting
us prepped and un-nervous,
she gave us a page of,
these are terrific
transformation stories
you can tell.
We were literally
reading them while we
were getting our mascara put
on, and I was tearing up.
She was like, stock tearing up,
you're ruining your mascara.
But we're touched
every single day.
There's barely a time
that I am in a studio
that I don't bump into somebody
in the lobby who tells me
something new.
And you really have
to step back and take
a deep breath for
a minute and think,
this is incredible that
we're such different people,
and we're all being
touched by this in a way.
That's what Elizabeth said.
It's just such a
human experience,
to feel strong about yourself.
SASHA ARILANTO: I want
us to watch this video,
because I think it just really
captures how y'all are scaling
that life changing piece.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-If I had to tell someone
to go to SoulCycle,
I would tell them that
it's the best thing ever.
-There's no judgment involved.
You just do you.
And you do yourself to
the best of the abilities.
-For years at SoulCycle,
we've been riding and raising
money for charity.
And we thought, if
we could get to kids,
and we could start to
teach them the benefit
of a healthy lifestyle and
community, that we could really
change people's lives.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC BUILDING]
-I've personally
had students tell me
how impactful the job
readiness program was.
For years, they've
wanted to make a resume.
And they were able to after we
spent a few minutes with them.
-I have encouraged my mom
with making new choices.
So we went to the grocery shop
together, and we bought fruits.
And that's something
that I never do.
-As a riding buddy,
we meet twice a month,
and we ride together.
After we ride, then we
usually chat and really just
connect about what's going
on in our daily lives.
-She just encourages me,
helps me with my college
applications and my job.
She gives me advice.
So it was very helpful.
And she's the best.
-She just makes me so proud.
-The most inspiring thing about
the Soul Scholarship program
is when you see the kids
sink in to what's happening.
When the music happens,
the lights go dark,
and they start to
lock into the rhythm.
-When you get to ride in
a room with those kids,
it changes the air, the
molecules of the broom.
It reminds us that we're
riding not only for ourselves,
but for each other.
-You see them start
to kick in to what
they know they're capable of.
-And then getting encouragements
from the instructor.
She was like, you can do
anything you put your mind to.
And it helps you push
yourself in life.
-After class, I feel different.
It makes me feel
good about myself.
-I have the power.
I can change the world.
-I like the fact that
everyone knows my name.
That was a big factor for me.
-When the teacher first
told me about this,
I didn't believe I
would take it this far.
I didn't think I would
be here right now.
It really inspired me.
-It does not take a lot
to change someone's life.
And I feel so personally
lucky that I've
been able to help and contribute
and be part of this program.
-Definite changes have happened.
Truly, I think we've just begun.
This was the spark.
And now they're on the journey
towards finding themselves
and developing self-confidence.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
SASHA ARILANTO: See,
it was worth it, right?
Thanks.
I have to tell you, when
I saw that video-- I
think it was maybe MK posted it,
or it was just on the Facebook.
It touched my heart.
Like a little bit
for these kids,
but also because I was
like, this is how I feel.
It made me mad, too, because
those statistics are so
upsetting.
About how people don't
get to have that fitness,
and their children.
It's a huge disservice.
So I want to ask, what was
the inspiration for this?
And then, one of the
questions that we actually
got from a Googler
before we start the talk
was, what's the long
term vision for this?
ELIZABETH CUTLER: So, like
they mentioned in the video,
we have always done
a lot of philanthropy
and money raising
inside the studios.
For any cause--
pretty much any cause.
We raise millions
of dollars a year.
It's kind of amazing
that that gets to happen.
And it's great for everybody.
And we always had this
desire to have something
that was specific to SoulCycle.
And there were some
kids in Los Angeles who
were riding in the studios
and really becoming
a part of that community.
And the community was benefiting
from it as much or more--
or equally, actually--
with these kids.
And you started to see the
possibilities being planted
in them, where
they felt like, you
know what, I can be healthy,
and I can have a future,
and I can go to school.
These are people who just
have no access to anything.
So we felt like this was
a great opportunity for us
to do something very personal,
where we could bring kids
from under-served neighborhoods
that were in their late teens--
juniors and seniors
in high school--
and give them the mentoring and
the skill set that maybe people
weren't talking to them about.
And help them start to
frame things for themselves,
and give them access
to the studios.
And it's amazing to see what
their retention rate is.
These kids don't
have to do this.
Why would somebody
actually-- really, you're 17.
You're pretty cynical, maybe.
It's very high--
97% attendance rate.
And in fact, we had a
couple of kids get injured,
and they would just
come and they would just
want to sit by the door
to hear the messages,
because it just touched them
and made them feel better.
So just being in
that energy actually
moved the needle for them.
And I think the
future for this is
for us to bring this to other
cities around the country,
and to continue to pilot this
inside of all of our studios.
SASHA ARILANTO:
Before we do that,
we're just going to do a last
lightning round of questions.
Sort of an Inside
the Actor's Studio,
but it's Inside the SoulCycle
Studio, if you will.
So you have to answer and
you can't think about it.
If you were in an audition,
what's your audition song?
ELIZABETH CUTLER: For me?
I don't-- probably
Justin Bieber.
But I know that's Julie's.
I know that.
Sorry.
I feel like I'm
stealing that from you,
and I feel self-conscious
about that.
JULIE RICE: I might use
"Helpless" from "Hamilton"
right now.
It's an interesting choice.
SASHA ARILANTO: Favorite studio?
JULIE RICE: Favorite
studio-- oh, there's
no-- it's the best studio.
It's the West 72nd Street.
It's our original studio.
ELIZABETH CUTLER: I love
all of the children equally.
SASHA ARILANTO: Before
work or after work?
ELIZABETH CUTLER: Before.
JULIE RICE: Only before.
ELIZABETH CUTLER:
Sometimes after.
SASHA ARILANTO: Bit of both.
Best cool down song?
"Return of the Mack."
That's my best cool-down.
ELIZABETH CUTLER: I can't
answer that question.
There's so much great
music out there.
And that is what is so
awesome about SoulCycle.
People are making new
music all the time.
We get to listen to it in class.
It's fantastical.
You got one from "Hamilton"
you want to slow down to?
JULIE RICE: No.
I always like "Landslide."
ELIZABETH CUTLER:
(SINGING) You're never
gonna be president!
[LAUGHTER]
SASHA ARILANTO: Front
row or side bar?
JULIE RICE: Oh, neither.
ELIZABETH CUTLER: Second row.
JULIE RICE: Second row.
ELIZABETH CUTLER: Center.
SASHA ARILANTO: Wow.
And the last one is what
size weights do you use?
ELIZABETH CUTLER: Three pounds.
I'm getting to five.
Melanie is here, our CEO.
She did five pounds
for our Turn It Up 20.
And I was like, damn.
JULIE RICE: She's really
challenging us all.
Two pounds for me.
SASHA ARILANTO:
OK, well awesome.
Thank you guys so much.
We're going to do Q&A right now.
So whoever's bravest.
AUDIENCE: Every time
I've contacted SoulCycle
for a customer
service issue, I have
been overwhelmed at the
amazing response I received.
And that's part of my job here.
I work on the
customer service team.
I'm super impressed at the
way you guys can promulgate
your culture even through
your customer service agents.
So I'm just curious what your
customer service philosophy is.
JULIE RICE: Well,
that's actually
one of our core values.
And we say that we are
a culture of "yes."
Even when the answer is no,
it's every employee's job
to find the yes in that no.
And it's really the way
that we built the business
in the beginning.
We made sure that even if you
hated the experience that we
delivered for you, we gave
you as many free classes
as we needed to to make sure
that you had a good experience.
Or if you forgot your
wallet, we took 10 bucks out
of the register so that
you could take a cab home.
There was nothing
that we would not
do in the beginning of
this little business, which
was located in the rear lobby
of a building with no sign,
to make sure that you
wanted to come back.
And we've really fostered
that within the culture.
And today, and that's
really the way that it goes.
We run an in-house hospitality
and culture and training
school.
That's really what SoulCycle
is, Right We are just
a customer service business.
We'd like to think that
whatever the product was
that we were delivering,
it would really
be about our customer service.
Making our customers matter
is what we say our mission is.
ELIZABETH CUTLER:
Because you do.
JULIE RICE: Yes.
That's why it's Your
Soul Matters, which
is our e-mail address
that you write into.
But we really do-- something
that we learned early on
is that there are so few
experiences that you have
in the world that are
transactional, where you really
leave thinking, wow,
somebody cares about me.
And that is absolutely the
focus of our customer service
program.
We have one very
exceptional employee.
She was our employee number one.
She spends her life as
a cultural researcher.
She's all over, figuring
out the best ways
that we can continue to
innovate the way that we
serve our clients.
And it's really an enormous
focus of our business.
AUDIENCE: So I actually wanted
to ask you a little bit more
about some of the negative
connotations of SoulCycle.
Just to be blunt, I
think a lot of people
see it as maybe something
for rich, white, hot girls.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE] people are maybe
in a similar position as me,
where I've been to
a lot of classes
and I actually love
SoulCycle so much,
but I'm a little
embarrassed that I go.
I maybe don't want
people to know,
because I don't necessary
like the surrounding culture.
So I'm wondering if you've
thought about confronting that.
Or what you think about
the negative side of it.
ELIZABETH CUTLER:
Oh my, god, OK,
can we just talk about
that for a second?
Because this came up at lunch.
If you love something,
it's OK to love it.
And it's OK to tell people.
I love Google.
I tell everybody
the Google thing.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Nobody's embarrassed that
they're using Google.
So it's so funny.
I don't know where--
that seems to be
a little bit of-- I
don't know, have you
heard that other places?
JULIE RICE: No.
No, I--
ELIZABETH CUTLER:
Is that phenomenon
that's happening here?
Do we need to do some
turn around on this?
JULIE RICE: Look-- listen--
AUDIENCE: I definitely
felt [INAUDIBLE].
JULIE RICE: Listen, it's not
an inexpensive experience.
There are a lot of
things that aren't.
You could say the same
thing, right-- people
get their nails done.
Are people embarrassed
about that?
You're paying somebody how much
money to polish your nails.
It's not actually making
your heart any stronger.
You're not actually
any more confident,
and it chips in two days.
But I'm not embarrassed, nor
are most of my girlfriends
that get their nails done.
And so I think it's really--
you could look at anything
through any lens.
If anything, it
really is something
that's making people healthier.
And so I don't think
that there's anything
to be embarrassed about.
ELIZABETH CUTLER: It's
OK to love, everybody.
It's really-- it's OK.
It's OK to love.
JULIE RICE: I don't think so.
And we certainly--
really, it was
started from a place of
really wanting to create.
That's why we have no lights on.
It's why we ride in candlelight.
It's why our instructors are
trained to give you motivation
and inspiration, and not
tell you that you need
to work harder or go faster.
It is really built from
a position and a lens
of love and no judgment.
And it certainly was
never built in mind with,
oh, this is how you should
look if you go there,
or it's sort of
an elitist thing.
It was absolutely built
in the antithesis of that.
And so for us, I
guess we've never
really thought of it that way.
Because for us, we think of
it as a place for everybody
to come and do
their best and just
feel great about what they're
able to do in the room.
AUDIENCE: So at Google,
I think we really
pride ourselves on 10x
thinking and moonshot thinking.
How do we grow things 10x?
How do we reach for [INAUDIBLE]
that we didn't think
was attainable.
How do you guys view
that in SoulCycle?
Whether that's how are you going
to gain your next 10x of users,
or how are you going to expand
outside US values, or however
you guys are
thinking about that.
JULIE RICE: We should
let Mel answer that.
We don't think about
it at all anymore.
But Mel is here, our CEO.
And she could
answer that for you.
We think about what song
we want to cool down to.
[LAUGHTER]
How do you think
about that, Mel?
MELANIE WHELAN: Look,
it's a great question.
Are you serious?
JULIE RICE: Yeah!
ELIZABETH CUTLER: Yes.
MELANIE WHELAN: I joined Julie
and Elizabeth four years ago
as the CEO of the company.
So I've been working with
these guys for a long time.
I've been a total
fangirl since 2008,
when they first set me up on
a bike at West 72nd Street.
And I think one of the
things that has excited us
and has made us so successful
over the last 10 years
is we've put one foot
in front of the other.
And we have made sure that every
community that we have built
has been authentic
and grassroots,
and every instructor and every
employee that we've hired
has been part of our
community in the way
that they're trained and
developed and supported.
And so I think
these guys have done
a great job about thinking about
the moon and where that is.
And I think we have some
really clear long-term plans
for the brand and
for the business.
But what we have
done historically
is put one foot in
front of the other.
And that's what we're
going to continue to do.
To make sure that it's really
special if you ride with us.
It's a really
special experience.
And we want to make
sure that whatever we do
remains really special.
So longer term, we're
focused on three things.
We've talked about
this in our filings.
We are focused on
international growth.
We are going to take
that one step at a time,
and think about cities not
the global planet as a whole.
And make sure that we
go into those cities
in a way that's authentic to our
brand and to those communities.
We're really excited
about our retail business,
because we think there's
a lot of legs there.
And we're also
excited about digital.
And it's ironic to sit in
this room with these brains
and say that.
But we think we've got some
really cool ideas there as
well, and would love
to talk about that
with anyone in this room
afterward, any time,
if anyone wants to
be a part of that.
And then obviously, the
biggest growth platform for us
is just going to be
keeping the core on track.
We think we've got a
lot of opportunities,
a lot of communities
we haven't touched yet.
And we're just really
excited to keep going.
SASHA ARILANTO: Awesome.
Great question.
[APPLAUSE]
Let's do you.
AUDIENCE: Have you ever
thought of expanding
to different cardio
machines or [INAUDIBLE]?
SASHA ARILANTO: So the
question, for anyone
who couldn't hear, was, have
you thought about moving
to different cardio machines?
So in maybe a different format?
ELIZABETH CUTLER:
We definitely have.
SoulCycle itself is actually
a format that's-- the Soul
method, you could really
take it and apply it to a lot
of things, right?
What we're trying to
teach you in those rooms
is really about how to
become your best self,
how to become your own coach by
making your own internal voice
strong enough that you can
hear it when you're running
or swimming or on our bikes.
That's really our
goal for you, is
to train your mind in a way
that's adaptable to whatever
you want to do.
And so we've thought about it.
We can't build SoulCycles
fast enough right now.
It's a great problem to have.
There are so many cities that
we're just dying to get to.
And so we are going
to stay focused
on the SoulCycle for right now.
But what Elizabeth and
I really love and do
a lot of day-to-day is
we're still super focused
on building this brand.
And so we really
think that, by keeping
the brand itself
vibrant and evolving,
and making sure that our
SoulCycle classes are always
evolving and continuing
to engage people
in new and exciting
ways, that at some point,
if it makes sense for
us to take the Soul
and put it on a lot of other
things, then we'll do it.
We definitely will
SASHA ARILANTO: Soul power yoga.
JULIE RICE: Soul everything.
SASHA ARILANTO: All right.
Let's do Erica.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you so much
for coming today.
Sasha is actually taking
my first SoulCycle class
next week.
And I was wondering what
your biggest piece of advice
is for me.
I've never even done
Google Spin at Google.
So I'm a little nervous, but
I'd love to know your advice.
ELIZABETH CUTLER: I
want to try Google Spin.
Huh.
That sounds intriguing.
The most important thing is to
get there early, let somebody
set you up.
We have amazing people
who work in the studios.
And once you clip in
and get on the bike,
follow the instructions
about where the break is
and how to get oriented.
And then just let go,
and have the best time.
Let your brain go, let your body
go, and just try to enjoy it.
That's the best thing
that you can do.
And then it's interesting.
It's like any kind
of physical activity.
Once you do it a
couple of times,
you get into the
rhythm of doing it,
and it just starts to
become second nature.
And that's when you can start
to really push yourself and find
something different
on that bike.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
ELIZABETH CUTLER: Yeah.
Thanks.
I'm excited for you.
That's awesome.
SASHA ARILANTO: We've got
enough time for one, maybe
two more questions here.
Let's go right here.
AUDIENCE: Can you build
a studio on campus?
[LAUGHTER]
SASHA ARILANTO: We actually
got that question before today,
too.
So we have many requests.
AUDIENCE: Who would go?
I would go.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'll teach
the classes if you want.
ELIZABETH CUTLER: I
feel it coming together.
JULIE RICE: We might be
able to do it in exchange
for some digital expertise.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE RICE: Let us know we
should discuss that with.
SASHA ARILANTO:
[INAUDIBLE] time.
OK.
I think we saw a question here?
Smiley face?
AUDIENCE: I just had a question
regarding all the competition
that's come up since SoulCycle's
really hit its stride.
There's reality TV
shows devoted to it.
There are every sort of
spin-off you can imagine.
What is your guys'
growth plan with growing
against that competition?
And how do you expect that
to increase or decrease?
ELIZABETH CUTLER:
Well first of all,
I just want to say that
genuinely, genuinely, there
is such a huge, mega-problem
out there that people are not
moving their bodies.
We have so many
issues-- seriously,
global issues-- that people
should just start moving.
That's all that matters.
Of course, we want everybody
to ride at SoulCycle.
But it is absolutely
just great that people
are-- this is a conversation.
My parents drank and smoked.
That was their fitness activity.
How far can I lift my glass?
Yeah, I know.
So you've seen that kind
of change in just 30 years.
It's a pretty big
deal, actually.
And it's amazing that
people are having
that kind of consciousness
and realizing, oh my god,
I have one body.
I should take care of it.
And the fact that people are
getting inspired by the work
that we do.
We take our intellectual
property very, very seriously.
And so bad actors
will be prosecuted.
But that being said,
I think it's great
that this is happening.
I think we both feel that way.
I think we all feel that way.
JULIE RICE: We learned early on.
In the beginning, we used
to see imitators come out,
and we would make
ourselves mental about it.
And somebody once said to
us, high road, long view.
And I still have a
sticker on my phone.
I move it from phone
case to phone case.
But I do think that we try
to make the decisions that
are best for us.
And I think that in
business, in general,
when you start to look around
at what other people are doing,
and you make
decisions, in your life
or in your business
or anything, that
are about comparing
yourself, or doing something
as a reaction to what
somebody else is doing,
then it's not going
to work for you.
You stay in your lane, and
you make the decisions that
are right for your business.
And so we really
do-- we appreciate
what's going on around us.
As Elizabeth said,
it's a phenomenon,
and more people are getting
healthier because of it.
But really, we put our heads
down and we stay in our lane,
and we just keep going.
We created it for
us in the beginning,
and we continue to create the
stuff that we think is great,
and we hope other people are
going to think it's great, too.
SASHA ARILANTO:
It's irreplaceable.
There's not the competitor's
founders here at Google.
So you guys have got
the special sauce.
I want to say one
last thank you.
And let's hear it.
Have a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.